[Musique]
et c'est bien sûr nickel et demi d'euros
qui s'y colle comme chaque semaine
bonsoir bonsoir grégory comment ce tour
d'horizon par du basket féminin une
véritable démonstration ce dimanche 3
février les filles du chesnay versailles
en blanc et bleu se sont largement
imposés à domicile contre l'union
sportive la glacerie
le score est sans appel 75 à 39 on
appelle cela dans le jargon un score
fleuve cette 13e victoire de la saison
en nationale 3 a été acquise dès les
premières minutes de la rencontre avec 1
13 à 1 après quatre minutes de jeu
seulement
on écoute les réactions passé les
matches qui sont difficiles à jouer
parce que c'est une équipe qui est bas
de tableau clairement qui joue qui joue
son maintien
donc elles ont elles ont rien à perdre
elles ont avec les crocs donc faut faire
attention vos palais faut pas les
prendre de haut faut tout de suite
rentré dans le match est concentré on a
réussi à le faire donc c'est bien je
pense qu'on était sérieux on était
concentré et à la fin les cartes qu'on a
fait c'est je pense qu'on le mérite
cette victoire permet aux féminines du
chesnay versailles de conserver la
première place du championnat le lc v60
vite compte trois points d'avancé sur le
duo gravenchonnais angers après 14
journées des résultats qui permettent
d'envisager montée en fin de saison du
rugby à présent michael est là encore un
score fleuve
alors je sais que vous aimez quand une
équipe maîtrise parfaitement son sujet
jusqu'au coup de sifflet final
les rugbymans de versailles ont réussi
un vrai festival offensif dans le
championnat honneur les versailles et se
sont imposés vous le voyez à l'écran ce
n'est pas une erreur 88 à 0 à domicile
face à l'entente gonesse goussainville
14 essais inscrits la douzième victoire
en douze journées pour les joueurs de la
cité royale qui sont toujours en tête du
championnat et qui ne sont plus qu'à
quelques points de la montée en fédérale
3 et on termine ce tour d'horizon par
une visite de marc une visite aussi de
de poids à villepreux lui aussi aime
donner des roustes l'ancien kick boxeur
professionnel français est aujourd'hui
acteur jérôme le banner est venu donner
pour la première fois un stage de pieds
poings à une quarantaine d'élèves au
gymnase alain mimoun il est resté au
total trois heures sur place pour leur
apprendre des techniques de combat ce
sportif d'un mètre quatre-vingt-dix pour
cent vingt kilos de muscles surnommé the
bulldog of normandie était au micro de
notre journaliste d'un mètre soixante
marylène iapichino comme son but
terry qui se rapproche plus à lui
s'appelle avec du karaté de la défense
moi je sais plus ce côté on va dire que
ça prend une mitraillette et moi je veux
avoir le boss du coeur dont celui en
avoir de deux armes en main il faut
apprendre ça germe dans le dans la tête
du professeur le répéter répéter en fait
celui ci nous un peu d'espoir dans
toutes les disciplines
il faut répéter répéter révisé et répété
voir dans un instant nous recevrons dans
ceux de 7,8 sport de tv 78 l'équipe de
taï jitsu de villepreux qui invitait
jérôme le banner merci michael 7,8 sport
c'est bien sûr juste après ce journal